plusieurs dizaines de blessés selon le
maire 53 personnes ont été blessées dont
26 ont dû être hospitalisés parmi ces 26
il y aurait 8 enfants c'est le plus
grand nombre de blessés dans la capitale
ukrainienne depuis plusieurs mois il
s'agissait d'une attaque non pas de
drone cette fois mais de roquettes
ballistiques qui ont tous selon l'armée
de l'aire ukrainienne été abattu mais
les fragments et parfois c'est des
fragments très lourd même avec avec la
partie explosive qui n'est pas forcément
détruit dans l'air qui ont fait des
dégâts dans trois district de Kiev à 10
endroits différents comme il y avait 10
roquettes je suis dans le quartier le
plus sévèrement touché je pense que vous
voyez derrière moi les vitres brisées
les travailleurs municipaux qui sont en
train de sécuriser cette immeuble devant
moi il y a un autre immeuble touché de
manière similaire c'est
euh quelque chose de de traumatisant je
pense pour les Ukrainiens d'autant plus
à cause des mauvais mauvaises nouvelles
venant des États-Unis cette incertitude
face à la continuation de l'aide
américaine envers l'Ukraine voladimir
Zelenski le président s'est voulu
rassurant ce matin en disant que il est
en pour parler avec plusieurs
partenaires pour acquérir pour l'Ukraine
plus de défense
anti-aérien mais en fait ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui montre que même quand
les défenses
anti-aériens fonctionnent parfaitement
parce qu'ils ont abattu 10 sur 10 de ces
roquettes balistiques cela peut quand
même faire des dégâts et des blessés
assez importants le truc avec les
roquettes balistiques c'est que les
signaux d'alerte ne peuvent pas
forcément être déclenchés à temps s'il
les tirent depuis la frontière en Russie
depuis la la frontière avec l'Ukraine
ils peuvent arriver sur la capitale en
moins de 2 minutes